sexy balle samy naceri comment ça va
super bien je l'appelle le beurre aux
yeux bleus mais tu aimes pas vous aimez
pas qu'on vous appelle beurre ont
préféré maghrébins je crois bref elle
berce et sur les tartines le matin qu'il
est je le beurre aux yeux bleus bon
alors ça roule un ouais c'est le cas de
le dire ouais ça roule quand on va
parler de reprise
si le taxi 2 qui est bien parti pour
faire 10 millions d'entrées on est à
quatre millions avec ça sera plus que 10
alors on est à 4 millions on a fait la
moitié un peu plus de la moitié de la
vie de taxi 1 sur 10 je sais pas un an
d'exploitation mais il était à 7
millions et on est à 4 millions en une
semaine c'est incroyable j'ai vu là j'ai
pas encore vu le 2 mai je vais y aller
c'est bien mais tu es bien en arrière
mais c'était bien
donc vous avez battu les visiteurs vous
avez battu astérix wars est juste danger
pokémon
il a quoi de plus que le premier et le
deuxième par il va plus vite ah ça va
encore plus vite travail ouais il va
plus vite
besson a fait en sorte d'étau fait tous
les personnages à vous avez moins
conduit à cotisations ans dans celui-là
non ouais on ne pouvait pas j'ai pas pu
me faire plaisir comme je me suis fait
plaisir sur leur antre heures ouais
parce que s'il nous est arrivé un
malheur la foutue il aurait été dommage
qu'on ait de la semaine finie taxi 3
c'est déjà écrit dans la tête de l'ue
coin ouais ouais pressez écrirait c'est
tranquille c'est un bon boulot
maintenant je crois que ça roule quoi
faut pas tomber dans le ridicule et puis
jacques besson c'est un mec leur
intelligence arriverait attaques si les
extraterrestres
s'arrêtera mais bon les gendarmes y en a
bien eu 4 je veux dire je crois qu'on
peut se permettre d'aller jusqu'au 4
comme l'armé fatale et pourquoi un
cinquième s'il cats le public est au
rendez vous on se permettra de faire un
cinquième alors jusqu'à jusqu'à daniel
si vous aviez tout le temps des rôles de
maghrébins comme nous dit c'est à dire
que finalement c'est la première fois
même en france je crois que c'est la
première fois que il ya un acteur qui
s'appelle daniel et qui joue pas parce
que dans le rail vous et votre bande le
film de thomas gilou 94 vous vous jouiez
des gens de la banlieue est là pour la
première c'est la première fois que
ouais je crois qu'il y en a quand même
un petit peu il ya hier jeudi il ya sami
bouadjila il ya saïd taghmaoui qui a
réussi à peu à travailler aux états unis
je crois qu'on est et puis c'est pas une
mode je crois qu'on est on est on est
quatre cinq six la dent dans le milieu
du cinéma ou
où les gens nous commence à nous donner
je dis depuis un bon bout à bien avant
nous mais nous on commence aussi à se
faire notre petite place si on nous
donne déroule comme ça de français ou
alors si c'est des rôles de deux
maghrébins des jolis rôles couet proches
disent et roschdy zem approché médian il
pense que c'est salman rushdie a jamais
vraiment avant il y avait au marché arif
muluzi en france sharif et mouloudji
et on a parlé excusez moi mais ce soir
on a quand même parlé de du kid
génération d'ormesson pierre doris est
voulue teen show il jouait dans fiac run
away
bon alors le deuxième film c'est le
premier film taxi bon c'est un triomphe
absolu le deuxième film c'est un film
qui sort le 12 avril est un film
d'alexandre arcady qui s'appelle là bas
mon pays tirée du roman de rené donald
qui est un bouquin excellent voilà que
zoom zoom bon garçon je montre à la
caméra zoome s'était dit voilà alors
avec antoine de caunes mathilda may qui
d'autre noah quadra alors l'histoire de
cette histoire de d'antoine de caunes au
départ qui est une star de la télé qui
présente le journal télévisé un jour il
rencontre un vieil algérien devant la
chaîne de télé web os et se souvienne
j'ai rien lui montre une cassette où il
ya une jeune fille qui enlève son voile
devant la caméra et on lui demande
d'aller la chercher parce que évidemment
les très en danger ça se passe en 94
donc à l'époque avait le génial fils etc
et donc il part en algérie pour faire
sortir pour faire sortir cette fille et
il s'aperçoit que c'est la fille d'une
fille qu'il avait abandonné en 62 et là
on découvre que lui et pieds-noirs en
fait il avait complètement renier tous
sont pas ses pieds noirs et là je bac en
trois matches et un entrelacement entre
62 et 94 que je voulais dire c'est que
moi je
arcadis est quelqu'un qui m'a fait rêver
qui m'a donné envie de faire du cinéma
et je rêvais de tourner avec lui et l'a
donc j'ai une participation amicale et
j'avais envie de jouer ce rôle
de smet qui se bat pour la liberté en 62
et qui se bat encore aujourd'hui pour la
liberté et mon personnage est important
pour le dénouement de l'histoire et que
c'est une belle participation amicale
quoi c'est très émouvant - tous les cas
ça m'a beaucoup touché je suis sorti de
là j'étais beau votre père est venu en
france en cas à quelle époque
il est venu bien avant l'indépendance
il est venu bien avant dépendance il
vendait des fleurs dans les halles
il a rencontré ma mère tu es normande
qui est normande qui explique les yeux
bleus à la gare saint lazare et ils sont
plus quittés voilà c'est pas beau ci lui
a demandé de porter les valises et
depuis
alors votre père était donc peintre en
bâtiment après oui vous avez une enfance
assez modeste ouais dans un deux pièces
six enfants dans la même chambre mais
c'était bien ouais ouais puis après mon
père ici de taper pour qu'on bouge un
peu quoi hein donc la peinture il en a
fait un vrai métier quoi un don qui
s'est battu pour qu'on bouge de là où en
était pour nous donner une vraie
éducation puis de quoi aller à l'école
et puis et puis j'avais ma mère qui
était là aussi pour veiller à tout ça et
mais on était tous ensemble dans cette
chambre j'en ai mes frères et soeurs
mais c'était bien c'est là où on a
commencéà j'ai commencé puis mes frères
aussi à nourrir des rêves de cinéma et
leur faisait toutes les scènes de des
films d euros des fausses idées vous et
des péplums voilà un il y avait à dire
qu'il y avait il y avait un rideau qui
séparait la chambre des enfants de la
chambre des parents et où j'étais dans
la chambre des enfants évidemment et il
faisait des péplums y jouer recule alors
je vais faire au passage les cléopâtre
on va vous rappeler des souvenirs
saluent bien
oui jouer dans un impeccable j'aimerais
bien j'avais vraiment la tête à jouer
dans un meuble le dernier qu'on a vus
avant vous c'était cédric pioline donc
avis aux producteurs vous êtes bon comme
la romaine bien qu'alors tout de suite
votre idole c'était gabin si j'arrive à
avoir 20% de l'amour que les français
portent à gabin je serai ravi ça sera
vraiment l'aboutissement dans ma vie
c'est un mec
je veux dire tout ce qu'il a fait tout
ce qu'il a touché il a joué des rôles
complètement différent
je veux dire les misérables
le singe en hiver le clan des siciliens
et je vais le parrain il joue un avocat
y joue un flic qui joue un commissaire
gaza dans la ville
archimède le web tout ça ouais c'est le
mec et ouais franchement si si je
pourrai où elles ne seraient semaine 10
% 10 % avec sa semelle searle et
pourtant j'en ai redit pour sa voulu ce
que je disais cet après midi j'aurai
voulu
arriver dans le cinéma et avoir ma
petite place dans le cinéma ou au gabon
était encore là il ne serait ce que de
me retrouver sur un plateau avec lui et
pouvoir parler un petit peu avec lui
quoi et une scène alors ça aurait été
merveilleux faut se méfier quand on dit
je voudrais 10% que parce qu'il de gabao
parce que y'en a un qui voudraient 10%
de belmondo et s'appelle michel creton
attention alors vous rêviez vous rêviez
à jean gabin l'école bon ce n'est pas
très très très bien passé violent
pension êtres femmes plus jeter est un
joueur annoncé à vos parents que vous
voulez être comédien et il vous dit
crowley sans sur terre va bosser au
marché que tes frères quoi hélas malgré
tout vous y avez cru envers et contre
tous et
je me suis dit j'ai dit j'ai vu y croyez
pas c'est un peu ralenti arrivera pas à
mon pote c'est pas possible pas bon j'y
arriverai pas et je me suis tapé comme
un fou jallet alors j'étais pas préparé
j'arrivais avec deux trois photos
complètement nul décév et mal tapé et
puis je me suis fait jeter toutes les
portes à se fermer et
bah ouais qu'ils étaient vraiment vous
êtes pieds sami kwakwa l'anacr et
écrivaine à ces noms vous rigolez une
ambre ok mais j'ai pas le temps là
d'accord et puis je suis tombé sur un
mec bruno dolet way qui m'a été présenté
par ma prof de théâtre et c'est lui qui
m'a mis le pied à l'étrier qui leur
quine le premier film de gilles de
maistre elle venait de refaire un film
des réactifs de metz dont principalement
les garçons fidèles c'est lui qui vous a
donné votre première chance et
aujourd'hui vous êtes une star et vous
travailler avec lui ça s'appelle féroce
ouais on se disait tu rappelles famille
il ya 80 et avec moi qui leur kit tu
faisais tu avais une petite figure et
aient été coupés au montage j'en avais
parlé à tout le monde
d'y raconter à tout le monde tu vas voir
j'ai fait un film on ne sait pas dans le
film c'est vrai j'étais pas j'étais
j'étais comme un fou j'avais dit à mes
parents à tout le monde vous avez vu
vous m'avez dit non c'est pas possible
et tout ma charge et j'allais faire un
film je suis resté 15 jours sur le film
là et venez venez je suis arrivé
j'attendais ma scène j'attendais ma
saine gestion des massages à tonnerre
est un peu un moment donné au fond et
puis les bouches alors si vous êtes
arrivé une autre fois c'est vrai il faut
dire la vérité quand vous avez connu
besson
dont vous jouez dans dans les rayons
avec une cagoule et à la fin du tournage
b110 quand même le pauvre samy naceri on
ne voit pas quand même donc ça serait
quand même bien qu'on le voit dans le
dernier jour ils du coup tu enlèves ta
cagoule comme ça on va devoir mais
c'était une c'était une belle rencontre
c'est une belle rencontre et et
la gg j'ai senti que
que le mec il s'intéressait à moi
quoique que j'étais là et il parlait
avec ses techniciens il me regardait
comme ça et puis dit lui un machin et je
suis arrivé donc dans les moulins de
paris il y avait une scène où jean reno
se déguise en soit et puis il fait
semblant de se sauver il est blessé donc
les autres soit l'aide à sortir et m'a
dit tiens ça me tue l'avenir méritée on
évite acadienne jean reno donc c'est
génial pour moi je fais une cents avec
jean reno et au montage et de la fumée
partout et on voit rien du beurre alors
on va voir l'époque des galères de samy
naceri l'époque des répondeurs son
message le soir aidé et des castings
inutile magnéto
ok ça mais tu peux porter sa part perd
alors sa famille raconte nous un petit
peu qui tu es d'où tu viens ce que tu
fais en ce moment
je l'appelle la série ça les sort un peu
du milieu des sites et ils m'ont dit
fontenay-sous-bois mon travail et autres
je suis passionné de théâtre du cinéma
et du théâtre la fondation boris vian
je fais des marchés pour gagner ma vie
j'ai
essayé de courir les castings à droite à
gauche pour pour essayer d'obtenir des
petits rôles parce que ça me plait quoi
voilà pourquoi dira donc vraiment les
histoires de sites et de tout ça qu'on
s'est montré le consumer dans les cités
je connais pas mal de choses d'accord
je suis demandé d'être levée je mesure
combien 80
d'accord tu vas m'ont traité profil
ok tout notre profil
ok très bien tu me regardes
aujourd'hui triomphe
dans taxi on a besoin une fois c'est
émouvant
et gros j'étais bien je me plie et tous
ceux
et celles pour une eau qui qui qui fait
le casting et il m'avait dit là je le
saoulais je l'appelais tous les jours et
tu disais bon alors quand est-ce qu'on
fait le film away in j'attends je veux
il me dit écoute je vais faire le
casting à la une période d'essai de
passer son personne te voyais amène moi
une faute au tac tac tac je me suis
faufilé j'ai rien dit à personne je suis
rentré dans le bureau où j'ai sorti une
photo et c'est un peu mon c'est lui qui
fait le truc c'est génial de voir sa
[ __ ] c'est bien et voilà
image rose
[Applaudissements]
ça me fait plaisir pour toi c'est merci
alors il ya un problème quand même c'est
que tout le monde te dis enfin tout le
monde nous disait il faut changer votre
nom parce que saïd ça marchera jamais
naceri ça va encore parce que la série
ça fait un peu corse italien enfin bon
ça peut passer mais ça ne s'impose pas
et et vos parents vous disais c'est pas
une question de talent parce que bon
mais tant que tu auras un prénom arabe
on me fera jouer les arabes alors vous
avez choisi ses amis
c'est un surnom maintenant de ses amis
c'est plus que c'est presque plus qu'un
prénom nom ouais mais il ya peu de gens
m'a même ma mère mes frères aujourd'hui
ma mère - parce que je m'appelle encore
saïd mais mes frères mes amis les
copains tout ça ils ont pris l'habitude
de m'appeler ça me met surtout quoi
quand au début
les journaux de merde là ils n'ont pas
dévoilé mon vrai prénom pour
m'assassiner il n'y avait pas beaucoup
de gens qui savaient que je m'appelais
c'est tout le monde croyait que c'était
ça me donc même mes copains il faisait
super gaffe quand on arrive et puis
qu'on était temps des fêtes cinéma tout
ça mais rien qui faisait légal et
donc ça a joué le jeu et tout ça mais
c'est vrai que c'était difficile j'ai
même pensé un moment à m'appeler pierre
morel ou chairman
j'ai bien morel et je me suis dis aux
gens au jour d'aujourd'hui est ce que
j'aurais fait ce que les la carrière que
voilà qu'arrive enfin les films que j'ai
faits comme raï comme petit ben comme
tout ça quoi peut-être qu'on ne les
aurait pas donné
alors vous allez changer aussi vous avez
vous avez peu fait attention à votre
langage vous dit tout comme ça je kiffe
où ça
c'est fini ça qui vous êtes habillé un
peu plus hip hop a annoncé le succès
donc que vous trouver de la place au
restaurant avec votre moment chez disney
dimanche a pas de soucis vous passez
devant tout le monde voilà quoi il
malgré tout malgré tout quand même des
fois vous pétez un peu les progrès il ya
certains soirs quand même vous j'ai le
truc c'est que c'est
sur les deux derniers coups qui a eu
franchement ça valait pas ce à quoi j'ai
tout le monde qui n'a pas bu quatre
verres de whisky en boîte et puis s'y
retrouve au volant il sentait qu'il
pouvait conduire le pire c'est que j'ai
changer de conducteur s'était pas à moi
la voiture et vous êtes dénoncés en dix
ans ils mac ouais je vais dire que c'est
moi qui conduisais comme ça mon pote il
aura rien et les matières il y avait de
gros noms du coup ça mais bon j'étais gg
j'avais un petit coup moi aussi donc
j'étais encore avec certainement et
c'est même sûr parce que vous dites
quand même c'est que dans ces cas là
quand on se retrouve dans des plans un
peu quand on se fait serrer par les caf
comme on dit on devient vite un arabe
voire un boulot tout de suite tout de
suite ah ouais tu te donnes a vu samy
naceri là là là je suis contre les
entraves aux pieds les mains notamment
dans la cage sans chaussettes et puis
quand tu es dans le car est content mène
à l'hôpital pour voir si tard elle n'est
pas malade tu as une bonne ronde geste
sur la gueule et puis on dit sale
[ __ ] voilà c'est génial ouais
dites-le à la télé ça mais je n'arrête
pas de dire j'ai commenté dites le que
quand vous êtes star samy naceri tout le
monde est sympa avec vous mais dès que
vous avez un petit problème avec un
chauffeur de taxi la nuit et puis vous
en payez un peu et d'agents de police on
vous traite de nouveau comme un
[ __ ] voilà c'est vrai ben voila moi
je suis habillée par la redoute mais je
suis tranquille
rien
le rôle qu'est
bien alors comme on vient de le voir
samy naceri a eu des hauts et des bas
dans sa vie maintenant c'est le hall est
ravi pour lui alors c'est normal on va
lui faire une interview abendanon ne
bouge pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il a bougé ça me sert à
regarder mais j'ai compris un peu tard
qu il fallait pas bouger on peut la
revoir à leur faire de toute façon voilà
valmy un flic qui lui disent
bien on va faire une interview à tanda
[Musique]
elle a encore parlé
c'est toujours la même
mademoiselle quotas
franchement
bien alors samy naceri interview à peine
d'arn c'est facile le plus le moins à ce
que vous préférez en vous
ma sincérité en amitié semble à vue avec
gilles de maistre c'est que ce que vous
détestez en veut bon comme on dire quand
on pardonne pas
on a du mal à pardonner aux gens quand
ils font
des erreurs avec moi à quoi je sais pas
comment on peut pardonner difficilement
difficilement ouais vous faire chier
quoi
ce que vous préférez dans le cinéma se
retrouver devant une caméra bratton de
direction ouais
des fois c'est long un ouais c'est sûr
taxi 1 il ya 9 heures du matin qui
l'attendait toute la journée pour
conduire le taxi et à 16 heures quand on
l'enfilé la bagnole
il ya le fameux coup du viaduc qui dans
le film d'action le il y avait un viaduc
qui était pas fini de construire il
compte du che comme une bête et il y
avait l'autre diefenthal je m'arrête à z
et les ouvrez la porte ses fruits avec
le pied de mecs jeu je me suis arrêté
bien avant quand même mais c'est
vraiment le truc le truc là où on voit
que fred il est pro quoi c'est que tout
en ayant peur ni voulais pas gâcher
apprise il voulait pas gâcher la scène
donc il ouvrait la porte il freinait
avec ses pieds il disait daniel quoi il
faisait tous amis ouais c'est ça get up
ce que vous détestez dans le cinéma mais
tu es beau tu es gentil était géniale
sur un peu dans tous les métiers quand
même et beaucoup dans le cinéma beaucoup
dans le cinéma le plus grand moment de
votre vie
la nomination aux césars ouais les
espoirs
puis à la naissance de julian aussi bien
sur le pire
le coupage de du film
ce qui vous fait le plus marrer dans la
vie mon frère ah oui oui je fais du
cinéma aussi ont ils écrit c'est un
comique n'est pas bon c'est un fou
furieux et un cimetière et le réveil
c'est un fou furieux qu'est ce qui vous
fait le moins rire le racisme
l'endroit où vous rêveriez d'être si
vous étiez pas avec laurent et moi et
nos amis téléspectateurs et notre public
ce soir avec marie dans un plumard moi
ce direct voilà est l'endroit où vous
voudriez surtout pas être
derrière les barreaux les mecs qui sont
enfermés en ce moment
ce qui vous aide à dormir le soir un bon
lexomil
ne s'est pas dangereux les xénons si ces
données si tu le prends avec modération
avec modération un [ __ ] c'est pas
mieux j'ai changé j'ai première la
solution alors oui c'est ça non je
connais une tonne l'adresse de raymond
barre il fut c'est l'opium a annoncé de
trompes raymond barre c'est pas l'opium
c'est quoi non parce que j'ai bien vu
comment ou via confondues c'est de
l'hélium qui la fumée
alors si vous êtes à dormir c'est un bon
x1000 avec modération et ce qui peut
vous empêcher de dormir mari aussi et
puis way et puis une mauvaise journée
c'est à dire que je me suis pris la tête
sur un tournage et puis je suis pas
content de moi et je me refais les
scènes 300 x 400 froid et puis mari elle
a beau me dire ah ça y est c'est fini
c'est dans la boîte pour mort c'est fini
maintenant faut que tu remettre le
gouvernement ça ça m'empêche de dormir
marie est donc votre compagne et mon
amour voilà je le dis à nos amis
téléspectateurs ce que vous excite le
plus chez une femme
qu'elle est en vie et kaki et caf à
celle qu'a pas envie ah
mais c'est bien ça
tout à l'heure
est-ce qui vous excite ce qui vous
excite le moins
une meuf
vulgaire qui tease et qui pour pour
m'intimider ou pour me sortent toutes
les cinq minutes des trucs comme on y
croise ivoire montchamp truc
juste pour parce que je viens un peu de
banlieue et tout ça et puis que elle
essaye de jouer cette carte là ça m'est
arrivé plusieurs fois ou vulgaire quoi
ce truc je joue un peu banlieues
populaires genre catherine deneuve 3
qu'est ce que vous avez de plus sexy en
vous a mis dans votre avis apprends
demandera aux filles ouais je crois que
c'est mes yeux et puis la psychiatrie
les yeux souriait les yeux la cicatrice
tous et dont
elle n'est pas sortie jamila brision un
excuser de moins sexy
rien ils disent elle a bien quelque
chose de moins sexy je pense à avoir là
des trucs là mais non les poignées
d'amour oui dans le compère d'accord je
crois qu'elle vous trouve très sexy
merci au cinéma c'est normal de faire
quelques bides
bon dernière question ce que vous ce que
vous préférez dans le sexe la chose qui
vous plaît le plus dans le sexe flirter
ouais ouais est ce qui vous plaît le
mois
les trucs attaché traces comme ça même à
chaque
écoute elle salue je crois que nous
aurons jamais d'avancé sur tous les
fronts essayé pour savoir enfin ce avait
d'ailleurs non non j'ai pas essayé mais
vous plaît pas toutes les perversions un
peu comme ça il ya des perversions qui
sont qui sont peu glissé et puis il ya
les pour essayer d'effacer truc génial
et machin les anneaux dans les salles
des pinces à st brais s'il vous plaît
pas ça non je préfère le côté tu flirter
ça part en sucette à un moment donné tu
attrapes les cheveux
c'est trop chaud
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu